my name is usman counter to ray
i'm a child soldier during the civil war
in sierra leone
they usually call me during the war
cornell counter
i met this commander by the name of
major lamin jallow in the morning they
clipped my head
when they cried my head
so finally i became another alive
they began to train me they began to
train me began to train me began to
travel with me
different different areas they even gave
me a gun which i was using ak-47 it's my
gun i was using during the jungle really
during the war what i see with my eye
then that experience i don't want my
children to even see it then i
experience things that will change your
whole perspective of life
so the chat for our parents
you look all around the country for them
they did not see none of these people
so i decide i will leave
i will leave
luger to free town
so sooner as i came to freetown
i went to my sister my elder sister but
during that time my elder sister don't
have nothing so care for me
i pay with him break stones
no get water for people
clean people's house
do this thing because one i don't want
to be like my friends but i want to
become somebody in the nation
then i have kids you know that now there
is no way for me that i have finished
already with the education no job with
me
nothing i just sit alone even they are
even humiliating us at home this and
that will still keep the faith that even
most of my colleagues some of them are
not coming again to mingle in certain
societies because while they have
already been humiliated they need to
they accept the way the society have
taken them but like me i disaccept the
society